We are on problem number six.
If there is no waste, how many
square yards of carpeting is
needed to cover a rectangular
floor that is
12 feet by 18 feet?
So I can just draw
it like that.
And it's 12 feet by 18 feet.
And the trick here is, they're
not asking how many feet,
they're asking how many square
yards of carpeting.
So the easiest thing to do
really at this point, is to
convert the dimensions
of the room to yards.
And they tell us 3
feet make a yard.
So 18 feet, that's the
same thing as what?
Divide by 3, and you get,
that's 6 yards.
6 yards is 18 feet.
And you divide by 3,
you get 4 yards.
I always find the arithmetic
the hardest part.
4 yards is equal to
12 feet, right?
4 times 3 is equal to 12.
So now this is a 6 by 4, so 6
yards times 4 yards is equal
to 24 square yards.
That's choice C.
And the mistake, if you got
this wrong, you might have
just-- well one, you might have
multiplied 12 times 18
and gotten a very large
number and said,
oh, that's the answer.
But then your answer would've
been in feet.
Then the other mistake you might
have done is you might
have multiplied 12 times 18--
you might done this, 12 times
18 divided by 3.
Because you said, oh well, 3
feet is equal to a yard.
And that is a mistake because
you're now converting square
feet to square yards.
And it's actually-- you should
have divided by 9 because
there's actually 9 square
feet per square yard.
Why is that?
Because if I had-- let's
say this is a 1
square yard, right?
That means it's going to be
3 feet on that side, 3
feet on that side.
So it's actually
9 square feet.
So if you figured out the area
in feet first, you had to
divide by 9, not by 3.
That probably was the most
common mistake, assuming that
you realized that you had
to convert units.
Next problem.
Problem seven.
A certain scale only registers
weights that are
greater than 6 pounds.
OK, fair enough.
A person who wanted to know
the weights of a puppy, a
kitten and a bunny-- very cute--
weighed them in pairs
and got the following results.
Kitten plus bunny weighed
7 pounds.
Kitten plus puppy is 8.
And bunny plus puppy is 9.
This is by far the cutest
problem I've ever done.
What is the weight
of the puppy?
So we want to solve for P.
Well, if we're going to solve
for P, the best thing we could
do is we want to use these
two equations.
But we have three-- if we just
look at these two equations,
we have three unknowns
with two equations.
So let's use this equation to
substitute into this equation.
So let's say we want
to replace this K.
So we can use this top equation
to say that K is
equal to 7 minus B.
So if we substitute that into
this equation, we'll get-- so
let me just-- this is 7 minus
B, so we'll get 7 minus B--
and I'm just rewriting this top
equation, that's this--
plus P is equal to 8.
And then this bottom equation
still is B plus
P is equal to 9.
I could add the 7 or subtract
7 from both sides right now,
but I'm just going to actually
add the equations, because I
like how these B's are
going to cancel out.
I get excited about canceling
variables.
So-- actually, no let me
subtract 7 from both sides
first. So if we take 7 from
here, than this 8
becomes a 1, right?
I just subtracted 7
from both sides.
So negative B plus
P is equal to 1.
Now I just add these
two equations.
And what's minus B plus B?
It's 0 plus P plus P is 2P is
equal to 1 plus 9 is 10.
2P equals 10.
P is equal to 5.
Choice D.
5 pounds, that's how much
the puppy weighs.
Which shows us the bunny weighs
2 pounds, and the
kitten weighs 3 pounds.
Which is-- it looks like they
actually thought about how
much a puppy, a bunny and a
kitten would actually weigh,
which I have to give
them credit for.
Next problem.
Problem eight.
On a blueprint, 1/4
inch represents 16
feet in real life.
If a driveway is 40 feet long,
what is its length in inches
on the map?
So a driveway-- that's a
driveway, I don't know, that's
my driveway.
And it's 40 feet long.
So how many of these units
is it going to be?
Well, actually-- we could do it
a bunch of different ways.
We could say 1/4 of an inch
is equal to 16 feet.
If we multiply both sides of
this relationship by 4, you
get 1 inch is equal
to 64 feet.
1 inch-- I just multiplied
both sides of this
relationship by 4.
So if you want to figure out
how many inches this would
represent, you would say, well,
x is how many inches it
would represent over 1 inch
is equal to this length,
40 feet, over 64.
It's the same fraction.
And of course, if you divide
by 1, this cancels out.
So you're left with x, which
is its representation in
inches, is equal to 40/64.
Well you could divide the top
and the bottom by 8, so that
becomes 5/8.
40 divided by 5.
64 divided by 8.
x is equal to 5/8.
And that is choice B.
Next problem.
There's a bunch of ways you
could have don e it.
This is the way that
occurred to me.
Next problem, problem nine.
In the xy-coordinate system, p
comma 0 is one of the points
of intersection of the graphs--
OK, so they're giving
us two graphs.
y is equal to minus x squared
plus 9, and the other graph is
y is equal to x squared
minus 9.
If p is positive, what
is the value of p?
So they're saying that the
coordinate where they
intersect is p comma 0.
So we want to figure out the
x-coordinate where they intersect.
So the easy way-- you know,
they're tempting you to add
these equations and do all sorts
of things, but we know
that they intersect at the
point y is equal to 0.
They're telling us that, so we
don't have to do all this
fancy stuff.
We don't have to figure out
where they intersect.
They tell us it intersects
at y equals 0.
So y equals 0, what's x in
either of these situations?
Well, let's take this
second equation.
0 is equal to x squared
minus 9.
Add 9 to both sides, you get
x squared is equal to 9.
I added 9 and switched
the sides.
You get x is equal to
plus or minus 3.
And they tell us, that if
p is positive, what is
the value of p?
Well, it has to be
plus 3 then.
And that is choice A.
And you could have used
the top equation.
You could have said 0 is equal
to negative x squared plus 9.
You would've gotten
the same thing.
You would've gotten x squared
is equal to 9, x is equal to
plus or minus 3.
You would've gotten the
same thing either way.
Next problem.
I don't know if I'm going
to have time to
do it in this video.
I might have to do
it in the next.
Problem ten.
The Smith Metal Company's
old machine makes
300 bolts per hour.
300-- I'll call it b per h.
Its new machine makes
450 bolts per hour.
If both machines begin running
at the same time, how many
minutes will it take the
two machines to make a
total of 900 bolts?
So how many minutes?
So let's say m for minutes.
So the total number of bolts
they're going to produce-- so
bolts is going to be equal--
so this is per hour, right?
These are both per hour.
So let's figure it out minutes,
because they're
asking us how many minutes
will it take.
So if you make 300 bolts in an
hour, you're going to make
1/60 that in a minute.
So what's 1/60 of 300?
Well, 300 divided by 60
is 5 bolts per minute.
And this one-- what's
450 divided by 60?
Actually, I'm going to
run out of time.
I'm going to do this problem
in the next video.
I'll see you soon.